you
you
you
and it's not life it was there
you
[Music]
you
one moment I'll just come
and a lot of extremism
just really not Damon it won't just
cameras on our office fair Antony Oh for
me just just mute yourselves and I can I
use your ear you mics as a as a
guideline
yeah confirm the live stream is on chair
thank you thank you very well open
councilors to this meeting in the
grilled scrutiny committee this is a
poly meeting being streamed live to
YouTube and via the council the website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes of the minutes I have been
advised that the livestream is now up
and running if for any reason the grid
can no longer hear or see the meeting
over livestream we will adjourn until
the creation has been reestablished and
I ask the club to explain the procedure
for this meeting
Thank You chair microphone should remain
commuters at all times unless a member
has been called on to speak by the chair
this is to minimize background noise
members can leave their captain has
switched on if I feel nothing doing so
it enhances the debate if a member
wishes to speak on an item or join the
debate pleasing the Cape Miss biome
using your microphone and raising your
hand you may also use a chat function to
type speak the chair will then call on
you to speak as appropriate voting will
be doing so by acclamation a simple show
of hands will indicate when the
committee is an agreement if you are
disconnected from the meeting please try
to rejoin as quickly as possible if you
have any technical difficulties please
contact one of the meeting facilitators
as indicated on the meeting access
details if you're about to speak your
wait a few moments you join Thank You
chair right thanks Damon come on every
morning very and first of all do we have
any apologies for absence
I've not received a teacher never see
later yes I am no Richard welcome was
having an issue with his laptop I don't
know it's been called blintz though I
suppose you could accept those apologies
you'd let me know yesterday mmm
anybody got any declarations of interest
you
never this is a solvency so item three
minutes of the last meeting and a real
pad and seen and read the minutes of the
last meeting
everybody happy with it
you
silly Nigel Suzie first of all can you I
had a strong memory belief sue sent me
an email and I can't remember where it
was so I do apologize of when we were
talking about selection of scrutiny
review topics we were also discussing
whether we could look at the housing
crisis and the housing of the homeless
let's be specific right so yeah yes
chair do we call that
yes counts calm well I thank you and
council wide header an email and if you
remember yeah if you remember the issue
was that homelessness actually comes
within the community scrutiny committee
and they are due to look at the action
plan from a previous review on this so
I've spoken to the chair and he's quite
happy for you and councillor Whitehead
to attend and I've put your name on the
list for the governance officer to send
you an invite to that meeting obviously
to be there as observers but the action
plan will be interesting to see what
progress has been made since that
previous review okay thanks Vee we've
done the same point you in America did
you make a point
oh no our just approving the minutes all
fully firmed up to say I'm in favor of
the minute excellent thank you for that
absolutely
yeah right I think in that case we can
hear it do you simply take notes on the
minutes
if you sell a show of hands just did
just to prove them all right sure thank
you
thank you I like to welcome Jill telling
him this morning now in economic
development and she's come to consider
an update on progress from about the
economic development and are you here
just to speak to his Jill I can do I can
share what we've done
I brought my colleague Carl apps with us
and we'll be aware I've been with the
council now eight weeks and if you are
looking for some background information
cause much more on the growth strategy
we are we are considering what needs to
be in that post to co-lead 19 and the
council itself is looking at recovery
plans and how to support business and we
are bringing that together in a new
format and we considered by cabinet we
are aligning that to the let priorities
because they have got and the green and
agendas high up in that and as long I I
team broadband not tied everything about
their two priorities we want to align
our grow strategy that to maximize the
ability to get funding right Carl have
you got to do any background or any
future plans or anything we need to know
as regards your very [ __ ] by the way
yeah apologies flies my laptop camera
again very good
after I need to put on me masking just
like putting nails in the buns yeah one
of the main planks of our strategies and
Center regeneration as well so is it
somatically and designed and that's one
of the key areas could we recognize that
so probably in a postcode with nineteen
world and something that's going to be
quite important for us to focus on and
develop so we have the clay crosstown
deal board which is working on an
investment building for play cross which
is significant and quite exciting and
then we also have two other pieces of
work which is the Opie work which is a
one public estate review of a concerning
killer Marsh and I'm going to progress
that as well because we've secured some
additional funding it's a narrow dokie
working to hopefully and some projects
that we can start with deliver so that's
some of the things that were happening
in the background Coral Gables come on
start to pull this sort of together and
there are points that Lee and the local
industrial strategy the t20 I've done is
still in the draft stage at this point
but it is around clean growth and
planning for growth that's something
that we need to obviously make sure we
reference as GOI says because the anyway
wouldn't get in our post any gain
funding and our strategies is to make
sure as those policy links to regional
and national priorities
I thank old Nick cut bring you in on
this
yeah thanks I'm snakes and if I could
just ask him Jill a question she
mentioned aligning our plan maybe
elements of our growth plan to the left
and and d2n to which in turn enables
funding which sounds fantastic now this
is news this feels like it's news in
some respects but it feels it feels
welcome and if I could ask you how does
that look
well how do we align our plan with d2n
to what what are the mechanics are they
what do we do we follow their lead do we
do we come up with their own ideas and
they they adjust to our ideas how do we
align with with them let's plan right
okay well it's the let's plan covers the
whole of not a ninja and Derbyshire so
when there will be key themes but it's
up to each target now how that would fit
with its needs so it's very broad brush
and in what they will support and
they're descriptive rather than
prescriptive but what their their
policies aligned with what central
government are out there and to fund and
what they see is priorities as well and
what we will do is be more prescriptive
about what we need it for northeast our
publisher and by putting the Whaley
right the document is you identifying
that you have a need and like where it
is and what it is and that is your hook
to then be able to go back and get
funding to support that theme or
whatever else we need in this area so
the work we need to do is work out where
is it we need the support in what form
and that will be the hook that we put in
that we then will take us back for the
thread to or any other funding that's
available
you have that mean yeah I mean it's it's
exciting because it gives us the
opportunity to really dig into the
funding opportunities and like yo says
it aligns with what the government
trying to push through so to have these
these layers of governance aligned is
quite important you know and maybe I'm
not sure how it's been in the past but
I'm keen to see that that align so for
to see what that looks like you ain't
just connected to that really am i right
dealing in saying that there's been one
phase if you like that finishes with
this is from the from the d2 NGO in 2001
and then we start another one it's the
another sort of program after that that
date and I don't know if Cal knows they
so I've had a bit of involvement through
the County Council as well
oh and the other question is will this
post coleridge thing affect the funding
do you think will it be more or less or
will it will they just carry on as you
think I mean from my experience there is
a lot of money there and and it sounds
daft but the deal struggled to spend it
all because you're talking to millions
of pounds every bids got to be of a
business case and all that sort of stuff
and and the fear is or has been that if
they don't spend it all as v2 n 2 then
the detect of them and so if we can get
stuff in the pipeline the better it is
for northeaster be sure is my experience
I couldn't agree more and so there are
funding regimes that are coming to them
next year a lot of those were around
ERDF and what's happening as you can see
there's announcements at the moment
coming out where government of pumping
money into the economy particularly
around infrastructure and we are bidding
already for that
without even without the grass growth
strategy because we've got things that
need to be
and funded that historically have been
identified and obviously now money's
coming out we are already playing bits
for that type of thing so we don't know
what the bidding rounds are going to be
looking like at the moment they are not
releasing money and but what it will
look like in another two years I don't
know but we just need to be ready please
yeah if I ask Carla question please and
regarding ope killer Marshwood member so
maybe I've grown an interest in this I
had a parish life and we had a meeting
with the project manager we've only had
one meeting with them it's gone a little
bit quiet so Kyle mentioned some
additional funding is that the original
funding Carl at around was at eighty
thousand pounds for both both Ward's or
is there more than the eighty thousand
so there was there is more than 80,000
initially there is forty thousand
through the one public estate we managed
to secure another forty thousand
match funding on the business rates
Poland pilot which is across Derbyshire
so we've got 80,000 to do that work and
that's why we were able to extend it to
just a bit more than just Opie and I
don't reenact this respectfully but mo
be focuses on the publicly owns a
sentence in place and what we were able
to do with this business like calling it
is it spread out net a little bit wider
and and have a bit of a holistic view in
terms of the place and what we can do
with it and the council northeast our
judicial council has pledged 95,000 from
your best to save for you and I that
we're going to then take the report that
PDR Consulting of doing minute and Punto
closely finishing and then we're going
to take that and move that into the
stays where hates
business case ready so then as as Gio
was saying about that making sure that
we're at that point where we can start
securing or request
additional funding will be at that point
and the challenge that we've always had
in the past is that we've been able to
do certain amount of work but not being
able to get it to that next step and
because we just not had to take it on
and progressed the project so and this
has been about getting us to that point
where we're able to turn a desktop and
study of these men into actual projects
which can be delivered on the ground
could I just asked what his current
state is of ope please yeah would be
consultants are just and finishing the
final report a zombie's with them in a
couple of weeks to discuss the draft
they tend to report in for comment and
we provided comments in self partners in
planning and the county as well on the
current status of that of course so then
add work improve those comments and
we'll be looking closer to a final draft
and then with that and possibly not at
this stage once we've got the draft then
I'll go out to commented parish and the
the previous draft will gone to relevant
stakeholders at that point for those
technical points and then the draft that
we have will then go out to consultation
with our stakeholder partners and take
any feedback from them and then we can
send that back to PR to do the final
drafted report
I suppose maybe you'll be you'll be
quite keen on on that that repulse we
would you be involved killer Marsh
looking at you TV into he had myself
ranchers who talked quite a lot on
dresses in Jeremy canyons in in Atkinson
so no bouncing ideas of each others also
an important one you know it's easy to
just look at a parish level on the on
the four walls around around where you
live but it's also nice to see what
other people are thinking and doing and
Jeremy has some broader ideas so it is
yeah it is it is it is good to see that
so yeah I'm very I'm very keen to stay
in touch with it's not a mail call
outside just translated as much as I can
that's my she thanks for that well I
think in that case plural we can perhaps
move on to the next item and which is
item five its crew to interview and I've
got ahead in the tourism business and
non-business this has scoping review and
including steam setting ask you to coin
honest yes thank you chair and this is
something that normally we do in an
informal session but obviously given the
circumstances we thought it would be
better to do it in the main committee to
get things moving
but at agenda item five you've all been
sent a draft project plan which is the
scoping document and obviously Jill and
Carla here today for two purposes to
help you scope what you want to look at
and secondly perhaps to give some
background information as to where we
are as a council in this area in terms
of the scope in document you'll see
beyond there that the sort of things
that you're trying to identify through
discussion is what you're actually
wanting this review to achieve so
identifying your aims and objectives for
the review Kiku's is obviously about the
key things that you particularly want to
look at and obviously
the two officers are there to help you
with that with with that background
information but then even going down to
a practical level of who you want to
speak to
now obviously members will have some
idea themselves who we need to speak to
but obviously the officers or no the key
people within the council that deal with
this and also external to the council if
you wish to speak to any external people
who we can make approach to and invite
them to attend a future scrutiny to have
a discussion and then the other things
is documentary evidence you know whether
there's any open coming documents that
we might look at at the next meeting and
also the things that you might want to
do in a normal situation you might
consider you know do we need to make any
site visits do we want to go and talk to
businesses in a focus group things like
that so those are all options that you
can consider as your scope
anchor chair thank you very much and
well I'll get started on this I mean
I've been giving some full week we start
some with tourism business and
non-business and it seemed to me quite a
big subject personally and I'd like us
to get sort of sort of deep down a
little bit some local stuff rather than
the great big projects I'd like us to be
looking in I don't know stuff we can do
in our own parishes that that are going
to enhance our parishes I don't think
what everybody thinks about about that
is I mean the biggest looks great but
the small stuff is important to the
people we represent us in as the biggest
of them and it's probably that there
that we'll probably make more of a mark
Nikki go handle
yeah you know thanks surfing company um
yeah I mean you're right I think we we
all would like to focus on on certain
areas obviously this is growth screw
today and not growth planning and we've
had conversations previously about
having input into the plan so growth
scrutiny has like pre scrutiny of the
plan
there's appetite for that talking to
Carolyn cabinet member cabinet holder
and I think that's really important that
and I would say Anthony that's where we
would feed into to Carolyn's plan to
ensure that we can get some specifics
and and and direct you know as much as
we can do what you just mentioned and so
I I don't know where we go from there
and I see one for Jill as well but I
don't where we go from the in terms of
how we formally can have an import into
the growth plan pre you know in draft or
in beta version yeah it didn't with that
cuz I mean the the information that sue
sent out they were a lot in there and I
think there's a lot to weigh already
been done on the tourism and stuff and
I've got the I'm right in front Emir as
well book just just the last paper that
you send and I'm focused in on the
weaknesses that you picked out in this
paper you know the poor district level
connectivity there's no district capital
like a visitor attractions and I think
and it does fit in with both viewpoints
I think that we need to focus in on
their weaknesses and now we can improve
them I think that's if we can deal that
as a committee and try and tackle some
of those issues then bullet points then
feed that into the into the thing which
I think with what you call it added
value with we've done somewhat I don't
know you because you're new to it Jill
and I know you've asked impact us on you
know what the maniac
and there are quite a lot missing out I
mean you sorta blase do when you live in
a village or whatever you don't rely
kington got a lot to history north wing
fields got a lot history you know which
agency which which we don't sell at all
and and things like that
and we've got good you know where we are
but we need to make it better you know
that the circle routes they name there's
a lot of way it got into but they don't
connect up and things like that whereas
we if we can feed that into it and and
and and I think it's be muted in other
places it means a lot of authorities ORS
County pete district highways working
together and gain it a joint strategies
so we can we'll all say the same thing
you know if we can do that and I know
that off a bit they book if we can so to
have that as as focus and feed it in
rather looking back so we're looking for
without we can make things better
that's where I'd like to do personally
and I think it you don't contradict what
either of you said I don't think can you
pick bones out of that I don't know what
I've said no no I don't you say sort of
things as we say we're local councils we
local councillors and we are Aries and
we I think we just take it for granted
we just take the brunt of what we have
and if you look long and hard at what
you're have then we can bring these
things before and would improve the
tourism people coming I mean we live in
a beautiful place so why not try and get
a minute you know we think we've already
got a maybe maybe come up with our ideas
for our own areas which we can I'm not
trying to create policy but what we can
add into the we growth strategy and and
you know stuck this there's a central
body they'll not perhaps see that we can
beacon I mean same as you know I'm going
on you soon be having you in
yeah I mean I'm on one level I'm all for
this I I have a passion for the five
been absolutely my godsend during
lockdown and I want to celebrate it I
want to get it out there I want to
publicize it but I can't help my head
thinking about national policies and the
impact of hs2 so um I understand what
you're saying and I do agree with you on
one on one hand but we we can't ignore
the fact that a big train track is going
to be yeah right through my village so I
don't know you know I can do all the
promotion of the five Brits trail but in
five years time or 10 years time
whenever they decides to start building
it it's gonna be wiped out so I just
wanted to add that into the mix because
it's national policy affects us whether
we're just local councillors are not it
all factors yeah yeah I can see that so
yeah and you know he's not coming
through John field
why don't we don't go Austin nothing on
the pad somebody call I don't know and
you know I can't appreciate like yes
Thank You counselor so and I cuz I'm
coming from the outside so I'm kind of
got a different birds idea very the
thing that I think might be really
helpful for me and the team is
understanding where you want to place
north east are be sure so we've done a
load of research that we've shared with
you and what I mean I think it's
probably simplicity struggling with is
do you one northeast arbiter to be a
destination in it's over at night in
which case one why would people come
here and watches the to see which we've
been trying to capture or if the other
part of it is is
supporting what goes on in the wider pig
district as this is a location to come
and stay come out for the night time
create a nighttime economy so they'll
though you may be visiting into the peak
going out walking actually you staying
northeast I'll be sure you go to the
lightbox you can go and go to the well
dressing where is it we want to pace
ourselves because if we want to be a
destination in their own right what is
it we're trying to sell and that's the
bit I am struggling with because I'm not
I'm not seeing it at the moment so we'd
have to I think create me yeah thanks
Anthony
so we with floating the idea of looking
at tourism business and on business
which which I think you know is a valid
point obviously post Co bid is a
game-changer I'm not sure if that
changes that or should have change our
thought to approach I don't know yet and
it's quite hard to understand that
clearly businesses needs support and
thoughts about businesses employ people
and that's how the whole economy works
so if got we've in terms of the growth
plan he's got to be business led now
whether we focus that on tourism or non
tourism warehouse jobs office jobs
innovation whatever but that doesn't
mean that we can't focus on an area of
that what I will say is that killer
Marsh is at the very top corner of a
district connected well connected with
Sheffield and Bolsover
you know with subset of the district and
next door to is a tech important which
is another 10% and then john field so
you know the three the three villages
across the top of the district make up a
huge chunk of of the district's
population in a small area when you
compare it to air in it again that
doesn't mean that a growth plans should
just focus on those areas absolutely not
but if we were
if we want to start knitting together
these things of business growth of
supporting residents and then obviously
tourism which is outside of all that or
may play a part in it we neither we did
we do need a cohesive approach to this
and obviously we'll know throughout our
ideas around in his probably Jules this
is Jules Java supposes nature i've
knitting it together work out what it
looks like but oh yeah i just want to
put on the radar that we've got three
villages at the top top corner that make
up a huge part of our population sort of
such a small area and businesses are
going to be quite important in this post
koban area
yeah thanks Nick welcome Richard yes
thank you I was on the phone I was on
YouTube and I couldn't speak then I was
on the phone and they want to interrupt
just really I thinking I think we all
wrote in a way saying some of the
similar things I mean I think there's an
opportunity because there's a new growth
strategy being developed in the new
tourism strategy being developed I'd
rather be I think we all all agree we're
on before words thinking than perhaps
looking at what's happened in the past
because there are new documents there
and it is a gray area between the
ability to amend something is it cause
you're not policy and just also the
locality element of this I mean you know
with a council to talk about you know a
particular attraction in the south of
the district which I don't know but I do
know you know if you're looking at the
moss Valley there are a lot of
attractions here and I think probably is
that a way of finding a method where the
very local level at the town or village
level we had that knowledge about what
was it what is not what is in our own
area so I don't also emphasize the
county are not of this and the import of
the of the individual communities yeah
it's just around the virus really we
need to recognize that the impact has
been quite sec toriel really so retail
has been heavily hit and tourism has
also been heavily here whereas some
parts of the economy been able to you
know continue to operate possibly not as
as well as as they went before the virus
but and potentially they are going to
bounce back fingers crossed we forget
that v-shaped recovery and what we I
suppose we need to recognize the tourism
strategies a lot of tourism businesses
are struggling now I'm going to continue
to stall and potentially are going to be
the last and set to recover from the
virus because the impact for people
going away on holiday or staycations or
that sort of thing that might be a long
time before every is comfortable to do
that in an appropriate way so I think
the business elements absolutely I think
we have to recognize a buyer
had a significant group from those
sectors and and as other people said
yeah it is about looking forward and on
what we do differently this presents a
real opportunity for new ways of working
and were principally doing this meeting
and this way so it's do we work with the
sex to see how they can and innovate
evolve as we move forward we've started
to change to other ways of working we're
doing already so we're doing a business
engagement event and but now we've
refined that to an SEC toriel focused on
to tourism and we would speak into
tourism businesses to really understand
because they're the experts in their
field to understand what are the impacts
on them what is it that they need and
what is it that they want from us all
and can we actually deliver what they
need a month so we've started to change
some of our thinking away I suppose as
as a economic development Union
yeah thanks Carl thank you I think Jill
you can see just from a little
conversation here we we awful desperate
to get involved in this and it's it's
the best way that we can get involved
with you a guy I don't really know and
say well it's not our it's not our role
to be creating creative policies really
to scrutinize but and there is a feeling
past week the scrutinize the items to
get them it n't into into your thinking
and maybe I don't know Richard are you
wanted speed just Holly because you
really let's try to scroll across so I
could see everybody but I can't scroll
it's cool I'm still thinking of Jill's
question actually and I think it is a
fair question you know why we a
destination it is alright or or or a
dormitory for the P district in
Chesterfield and I think could that be
our focus as this committee to start one
of the focus to actually answer that
question ask people basically but if
we're gonna deal with that we then need
to know what are the attractions my gut
reaction is that the first really big it
year attract people because we cheaper
than the stadium feed district but we
aren't Edgeley
we've got theaters of stuffing
Chesterfield and Sheffield and and
people can stay in xington and kill
Amash I think I'll not be on card and a
mansion killer mash but if somebody
asked me where I wanted to stay it won't
be clay cross I'll kill her mash and at
this point in time bought if we if once
you're there to visit these other things
then you then you have the other stuff
and and then they wear the mouth or
whatever and and yeah it's a bottom-up
thing but at the moment I think the
attractions that peak district and Jessa
feel most Sheffield in your in the north
so but they they the sort of questions I
think we should be asking
of local people officers and and the
business community and see where how we
move on from that I'm just trying to get
a focus for that for this actual
scrutiny yeah yeah Thank You Nigel
thanks for that Richard yes I agree with
what Nigel says but one thing is put in
place is a bit of a detail point when I
read that tourism strategy mostly there
was an obvious point that the attraction
war website the area but the two things
I focused on what is the things we which
i think is important which is full
plasma that bridle ways you know the
most fairly the trails I think are an
element where you can attract people in
the rotary war you know it's not yeah
all the footpath on to look in a great
state so there is certainly an area in
one area I think where people would come
into the area the other one on the
dormitory does lead unfortunate and this
also stems from some work I did
analyzing business ratepayers in from
field if you then stray into supporting
you know cottages and second homes and
obviously that has an impact in
affordability and you look areas like
the Cotswolds and cold water depth where
local people have been priced out of the
market have being able to buy affordable
homes identifier one which perhaps
wasn't particularly in there was a
Venice and again again is just again
down for the currency element we are
considering at our level we've being
told that maybe we should be looking at
upping and I'm talking about local
events I'm not talking about you know
Glastonbury or anything like that
but just up things to have our Christmas
fairs and summer colors and things in a
local way with community partners that
wasn't particularly in wasn't I wouldn't
expect it to be in that paper on tourism
but I think it is it's it just provide
that thing about why would someone
commit and I take the point about the
theatres yeah yeah thank you
and today yeah I mean kilowatts for
example is is is just off the motorway
which is really handy
Calathes kingdoms being built at rather
valley and we've got rather valleys well
which is a fantastic attraction all
things outside of our district but I'm
sure commercial benefit one way or
another from that as well as the canal
going through in the next ten years and
being connected up so kill much you've
got some really good things happening
and to be fair in terms of this
committee obviously we I think we turn
up the quantity towards their tourism
and on that side it feels like right now
what's happening is the one public
estate project which is has tremendous
amount of the funding available if we
can really nail that you know we've got
a two thousand pounds of the budget just
to spend on on reviewing the
possibilities there I would really like
to ensure that this committee
scrutinizes that to the tee to ensure
that we can maximize any opportunities
we've got there that that will deliver
although that could certainly set us up
to deliver some of our long term gains
with this backed by government funding
so it would kind of halfway there
already we just need to make sure that
we put that case together so I would
certainly elevate one public estate in
this in this committee
it's
you
this we view do you want to do the two
prongs or you want to focus on one side
obviously if you do the two and this
plenty of scope to do that within the
ear but you will want to look at some of
those key documents at a future meeting
because obviously those are the
documents that are going to steer where
where they fell which is taking this
so Richard you you're like once you know
you might know it just to say just to be
so so we could have a I think he is too
long but we could have a short project
which is feed comments into the emerging
growth plan and feed comments into the
draft tourism plan is that we saying so
is that that would be a valid piece of
work for us to do the only thing I think
a year is too long shorts in the year
that sorry chair yes I'm trying to get
you could actually you could actually do
that as a separate piece of work if you
want to or you could make it part of the
wider project chip you know it you know
that will take possibly the municipal
year because remember you only have
about five or six meetings going to do
that two pronged looking at the
overarching policy area and what that
meant on what you want to feed there and
then from that leading onto that local
aspect that you're trying to put into
that but it's it's really up to the
committee decide what approach wants
then perhaps Jill might have to give us
some advice what she thinks
I think if Jill could just go through
their own timetable because to me
there's no point in a piece of work will
take a year if the growth strategy is
going to come out in three months so I
just bring Johnny they just been waiting
you'll wants to make a comment John yeah
thanks yeah we've been listening
carefully if you remember the whole of
last year we waited for the growth
strategy to appear and it's difficult to
set the scrutiny to people if the
council home guard strategy so we
wouldn't know which way to to scrutinize
the tourists tragedy is fairly close to
coming forward and the growth strategy I
think he's seen cabinet they're not sure
what state is that so Jim are going to
give us an update on that but I think to
get a teeth into a project or a mini
project apart like the one people's to
stay that's already up and running
they're already looking at gaining
funding I think that storm
we could put down as one of our topics
yes yet the fact that there is no real
we we've had some time now just and I've
said this before well we're just not
going around in circles but we haven't
really got anything particular to get a
tea into so an inflation sort of really
what you're what you're saying what
you're saying and what soon as mentioned
and Richard said about Neil feeding
comments it I like that idea as well
it's something you can accent its limit
and breathe in you can actually you can
actually make a point where the rest of
it just being around in circles a little
bit without being a Jill Muller just
sorry you into doing there yeah it was
just to say that we're expecting a
tourism strategy to come to be finished
drafting by September to be adopted by
the council so for me it would be really
helpful if you looked at that and fed
into it because that's the bit of
struggling a little bit about where our
focus should be and you've got half and
then shortly after that really expect
the grouse which that's gonna be
slightly I take slightly longer because
there is lots of work being done and
detail into Anna Derbyshire level to
understand the effects of coded nineteen
I want to make sure all that's captured
in the growth strategy so that we've got
a document that we can use going forward
but you can find with other local
authorities they're gonna have to do
something with their growth strategy to
realign them and I don't want to have to
do it twice if you're doing it we're
going to do it right and it aligns to
everything so that will come probably
knocked over time and I would imagine
awesome [ __ ] out the way thanks tools
that make sense does that make sense to
little buddy
it makes perfect sense to me a lot but
you'll see I think I think it's so that
you can actually feel and and discuss
comfortably because it's it's piece of
about all of you learn at something that
yeah well stinky FM I think she was like
then the initial part should be about
talking about these you'll find your
comments around the strategy as drafted
but then it might be that and it could
be for the this cabinet or this side it
serves crucially committee next year
then reviews the first year in hopefully
post go reads 19 what is the strategy is
it to live in what we needed to do so it
could be that we do that review next
year on the strategy in Italy go in the
direction that we were predicting now
and do we need to make that amendment
there and that might have some real
value as a midi review of where are in
where we expect to be and where do we
want to be so it might be that it's that
first part around the strategy add your
comments and where you think is going
and then any years time is reviewing to
say well actually are achieving the
expected outputs because at this point
would make a certain amount and educated
assumptions but they are still
assumptions at this point and it could
be the you know the economy takes a
massive tank or it could be the copy
company bounces back really well and we
need to taking a slightly different
direction so you might be able to go
five protocol so soon can I just come to
you we we've had we haven't keep having
these conversations don't we do an iron
and we keep just slightly moving and
what what we're going to do I think
because I think that a Syrian a
reflection of having no real subject to
work towards him at this point I love
the idea I love the idea of feeding in
beanie Commons but to class the rest of
the the committee how do they feel about
that Nigel what are you with you Nigel
you are the attorney yes again thanks
for pulling me out stop thinking I was
thinking I'd make I would think you know
well yeah and yeah I think I'm just
looking at this September Dale are
really that look there's a lot of time
to feed stuff in that's all I'm
questioning really a lot the idea and I
think I mean more I've read it you know
it is a long way down the line I think
we've said a lot today you know we've
all got different coming at it from
different angles I'm feeling and but as
a starting point I think I think we can
deal that in it in a larger quick but
let's also really study what what's been
done so far
and we can have an input into that it is
neck meeting and then after that we can
move on up but I believe we've we've let
things do settle a little bit and then
we can start looking at the the bigger
picture and and there's two aspects in
there's the bigger picture and the local
you know each each what can we sell
where you started from Anthony you know
what's each village got that we can feed
into that into the thing and with all
we're all from different villages and we
can all make a case for our little
village book it's probably a bigger
strategy than that and and and I'm not
clear deal to be on
exactly where we fit within this area as
as what we are I'm not clearing myself
to be honest so but at this early point
less less just focusing on that strategy
and and how we can import into that does
that make sense so I don't know okay I'm
coming
yes that was just what I was thinking
that putz you start with that strategy
put your comments in and when you do
that where you go next will become
clearer and you'll also hopefully have
the growth strategy available to link
into that and then decide what piece of
work because she could do mini bits of
work as you go along it doesn't have to
be all at the same time I don't know
what you think about that
yeah yeah thanks I think just Suze let's
come in yeah it's an ongoing piece I
mean let's not kid ourselves we're no
economic experts you know no there's a
economic experts and we've got no idea
what Kobe's in the green post Kobe's
gonna bring it's got to be fluid it's
got to be dynamic and this this
committee can be part of form part of
there and we can raise the flag when we
see things so so just just to maybe you
know to summarize things are we talking
about three things are we talking about
input into growth growth plan input into
the tourism plan and some kind of
spotlight onto OPA from those three
meter smiler that's my understanding
yeah I'm with that in order to try and
move things forward that they seem
there's loads of other thing to talk
about but it feels like you know they're
they're meaty things that we can now
that's enough through those three things
three big things I think yeah great
everybody else happy with that Susie you
happy
today right okay
anybody make any more comments for that
I would think for that means to eat
tonight am i am i okay to move on to my
next item he released what he's really
any more on that item
no I think they saw what I forward
dressed I'll start with the strategy
coming to the seventh of September
meeting and then obviously we can move
on from there I just mentioned that we
have had
ope in this committee before and being
discussed obviously it was at the time
and and the world's moved on since then
so it is something that fits very well
within this committees work so I think
that would be a useful piece of work
your your live on the screen are you
ecology do you want to say something
hmm no I'm agreeing with what Nick has
said I think that's a good idea
given that I'm new on this and I'm
listening
okay well that's
let's move on to item six shall we
forward one of executive decisions well
I think it's yes
chair just to remind the committee this
document comes every meeting and it's
considered breast pad just to have it in
so that members aware of the key
decisions that are coming up within the
near future and some members will be
familiar with it and obviously it's just
a way so you can you know have a look
and see if you wish two ways any issues
or ask any further information from
offices or cabinet I would also like to
ask whether Damon Stanton the governance
office could just have a couple of
minutes to talk you through because we
get this document every time and it's
also always slightly in the past because
it's a rolling formal document and so
some of the decisions you know might
have been taken or might not be being
taken on the indicative date that's
shown and there is now a new link on to
the website that allows members to get
the most up-to-date position on there
and we will actually improve to start
putting that onto the agenda so members
can have the hard copy document but then
can check whether there's been any
movement cuz there's often questions
from members that things have moved on
so it's he wants to just explain how he
can access that
thanks to day none of you yep yep just
in terms of accessing it then it's
fairly straightforward on the website
and in fact I'll go back and if you just
go onto the website and then it's
committees agendas and minutes and and
you go through to the forward ones and
then like Sue says he's a regular
updated so just click on the latest one
here and it'll give you an up-to-date
efficient status and so as you say
sometimes when we set me gender out me
before what plan can be out of date so
at least this way members are aware that
decisions are changing and what's been
done most of today
you
you
you
sorry Damon could you just show members
how to click on the links in the sort of
updated stuff they might get that won't
possibly be on the hard copy document
yep so obviously just a face on land
sales in terms of decision statuses had
item deferred yeah and you've got your
your reasons why and there's not really
much to it off a mark so it's just
whether members want to access during
the meeting for iPads they can see when
we move on to the ice and if you just
want to log on and you can see the most
up-to-date version that's available
today
eggwin how did you get onto infinite
where is it gingerly on page at so I'll
start again I'll go for it so go down to
show more services counselors meetings
and scrutiny committees agendas and
minutes
gov dot uk' and then at the side here
forward plans
dude my a probably where that term is
helpful it's clear now Doris I thanks
dinner very much and I'm already alright
with that
okay item number seven work program
consider the work program for the girls
truly commit and review the proposed
work so thank your chair I mean
obviously given what you've decided
today I will read it this to working and
you know the work you've just suggested
including getting an item on to a future
meeting in the near future to look at
the ope item as well so it's just there
to show you what you work is over the
year I had read you dick to on the basis
of you doing a full year's review and
obviously we've taken a different path
to that so I will read you it but it
just set out there's sort of things that
you would need to do on that you'll
notice at the ninth of November meeting
I had got to being the gross strategy
back because I had hoped that it would
be available by that day so that's
already scheduled in so that will fit
nicely for me September meeting looking
at the first piece of work and and then
on to that and you'll see that there's
lots of
[Music]
itens Ruth interviews written in
obviously what often happens in a review
you want talk to key stakeholders but
I'll have a discussion with Dylan Karl
outside of this meeting so we can decide
you know whether there's any people
instead own document so we've members
have any items that they want to add on
to this during the year if you just go
through me or the chair then obviously
we can discuss them and talk about
trying to fit them into your work
program later in in the municipal year
you usually have things like the
partnership activities in support of
growth team come in and tell you what
they've been doing
but again that's all up for discussion
and if you decide you don't want that
then we can take it off or if you you
know you want something else to go in
its place so I just want to really
members that it's you know it's a
working document and you if things come
up and obviously from the things that
you're here in you know if you've had
the LP item in and it sparks something
else then this scope in that program to
fit it in so you can pursue that forward
right thank you sue
thanks Anthony just regarding just the
opie specific is it PDR I think um this
PDR who's conducting the review for us I
would certainly like to get that min to
to talk to them and obviously hopefully
have some kind of whether it's traffic
or depending on what time we get them in
whether it's draft hopefully be drafts
11 in point to it I'm not sure if he's
one for Carl Oh best timing for that the
reports nearly coming to an end and PR
will step away once it's a funnel report
so it may be the is too late in terms of
when your next community is because they
may have done the project moved on to
the next thing and then that when
they're not going to want to come back
but it will go to the project roll board
and what project lost a group and the
project control board where the parish
and the districts and accounts are all
represented so they should they should
be adequate and chance for them to see
that before we can actually bring the
report to this committee and then we can
suppose talk about what the what next so
what do we do next I suppose that's the
important part of the Oh because for any
report it's only as good as what you do
with it Maxie if it sits on a shelf then
it's money well spent if you turn that
into an actual proposal that can secure
funding then sorry and that's what we
need to make sure we're doing so it
could be that we do that but this meet
depend on time
oh yes sorry how do you think I mean
Opie started freak over and think
against thinking specifically about the
ward and I've been in the meeting with
them so so I've got a bit of context
with it it do you think it's almost like
a different world now
so the data gathering the information we
provided at parish would be completely
different today than it was pre coded I
mean some of the challenges that we've
got now I was a parish and I'm obviously
the district they're completely
different and the opportunities that are
different and we've got we've got land
that we may now want to do something
different with Stowe
I mean this might be very unfortunate
that this coming towards an end but it
would be very disappointing receiving a
report there was for a different world
and we're in a new world is there any is
there anything that can be done there
colleges or do you feel that that's not
particularly a concern if all I see I
think what kind of in nineteen has done
this accelerated what was already
happening so I think the high street was
already in a challenging situation a lot
of shops in our town centers were on the
edge anyway and I think in a couple
years some of them were gone anyway
the nature of how we shop and use our
town centres was was always changing and
I think this is just accelerated I think
our town centres now need to be
experience based so you need to go
wandering by lies you need to go there
to do something and it's not about you
go there to buy some clothes or whatever
else and the Oh piece work had already
kind of done that anyway and recognize
that the nature of our town centres are
changing it can't be the anchor for our
town centers can no longer be retail it
has to be something else so some of the
things that we talked about for instance
was increase in residential within our
town centres well actually that still
makes sense because there still are
housing these so we know that but also
the more people you go on a hash on the
high street living there they're more
likely to pop to the local shop to get
some milk
place a bet or what
whatever it is it's offer on a
high-schooler point so I think the the
work the open work has done he's
probably right but what it is is just
we're an accelerated world now so
similar stuff that would have naturally
happened two three four five years has
happened over a case of you know
fourteen fifty weeks so I think the
lessons are still right and this open or
isn't you know it isn't casting stones
what they what they'll give us is
options for this Bissell and you could
consider it in this you could consider
usually in there and a potentially is
what we do were the next piece of money
is turn that into program say well you
know what we think that's right that
doesn't fit anymore so we're gonna go on
focus on put that proposal for tenants
or business case and see everything
secure so I still freeloading yeah
a green parked car but I do disagree on
specific so for example a kilowatt is a
literally so it's very unclear what that
what a letter this Center looks like
today you can during Kovac it said it
was a not very well functioning business
in its own right it it's clearly going
to be less functioning it's only going
to have more challenges so I think
things have changed very specific for
kill Amash we've got a an area this is
the pleasure center there's got four or
five local authority buildings on it all
owned by different people and a bit of a
mess and now Cove is literally to taking
the largest building on there and it
costs like nearly a million pounds to
run and it's only upside down and I'm
pretty sure the report won't won't work
cover that so so I do disagree that the
report will not be pertinent post Co bid
for killa marsh for the legislature I
mean that's
there's a very specific part of the
reports and I think the principles both
of the report are going to be right near
the the latest entering killing wash we
know that's a challenge and some of the
suggestions it's made of another Corp
host Cobra 19 were probably propria and
we need to review it to see if they are
still appropriate host cover 19 I think
what weird or something spec knows is
that the virus has made is changed for
now i relay centers will open at some
point yeah they will have a restriction
in terms of how they operate but in a
year's time to be is time or being
willing and well that there's no second
waiting with the virus you'd expect
those would start to operate in a more
normal kind of way that normal might be
slightly different to what it is now
and but that's that's something that we
can certainly look at and the report as
I said I think in broadly in terms of
principles he's right it may be the
specific part of the report aren't still
as relevant aside once were
so we're thinking just on that I know
yeah it's a big big eyes mom in your
your ward l sensors nyle sensor spoilers
well you said bless you and but you know
as we're moving forward as a group now
maybe we can actually make some comments
on that put some ideas forward because
obviously you're living it like garlic
elastomers though you you know is
passion your opportunity to say that's
that's maybe yeah I mean if I can yeah I
mean I know I know cuz obviously not
living and breathing it and I'm on the
Finance Committee of parishes on the
Sports Committee perishing I was
chairing finally so I'm absolutely in a
dieter and I think Carl's comments I'm
sorry Kyle but they are a bit
generalistic and I'm not I'm not
sympathetic to the challenges that we
face you know killer killer marshes
leisure center loses three hundred and
fifty thousand pounds every single year
every three years our village loses a
million pounds I'm pretty set for a
village and and that's in the good times
the the the ledger center needs an
immense amount of money investing in it
and then we're gonna come out of
postcode Post COBIT knowing that there's
going to be subdued effect on on on the
commercials it and he's got to survive
I've got a hundred thousand pounds worth
of general funds that's a drop in the
ocean
so no absolutely not
host COBIT free Killa Marsh is a
completely different story to precoded
and I'll be amazed if a rubric or will
will cover that and and we'll end up
with a with a half a half made before
because that that piece of London at
that arena is a is a huge part maybe
half of the hearts of collage and we
stay well you know we discuss what we're
gonna do over here with shops and
something's changed in the other part
and we didn't know that at the time and
and the report is is is now half our
plate so I don't know if you can extend
these reports you can maybe we have to
spend some more money on it I don't know
maybe it's a clown so we can do it
ourselves I don't know but I am very
concerned that we think that this trip
or will will cover what we needed to
cover that's everything
John we yeah just an observation really
if we're going to look at ope which
we've agreed with it's gonna be an
interesting debate from where I'm
sitting I can be quite abortional but
I'm not as close to it as Nick is
obviously is things like lettuce and an
infrastructure community support
activities a prior pretty important to
me so bridge testing to see what the
report says and now they budget take it
to the next step approve the facilities
and services around the community thanks
John Jim yes I was just going with the
OPA so and if with the legislating that
much nominee anyway that would have been
taking into account when it's doing its
okie work about how best to deal with
that and how death to deal with that
asset and you're right it needs to be
reviewed in light of what's happened we
co-lead 19 and but uh they fundamental
them the fact that that was losing so
much money will have been taken into
account so I think the starting point
for looking at it it's probably in the
right place and doing a review on it in
light everything else is good of the
cars right what's happened is things
that would have happened this time I'm
going to be happy in the next yeah next
two years and actually this could be an
opportunity for us now to look at what
it is we want to do rather than having
to do it in stages we just jump to where
we want places to be
yeah thank you thank you as anybody any
more points on this item in the work
program no okay additional urgent items
item number eight have we got any
additional urgent items so I have known
chair you don't take an urgent - patient
said until we could talk about that we
kill them off let's do since that was
sarcasm that is it very good yeah and
you're gonna get an invite now you're
gonna get an invite to visit now you've
opened imagine day to the next meeting
the previous item did we close off the
growth report to cabinet from two years
ago oh is that all being forgotten about
in there no it's out that was can I just
bring you in on that we're we're we up
all right Thank You chair I presume
Council for know you're talking about
the previous review on the business
centers industrial units one yeah yeah
if you remember the committee took away
the documents and I did send some more
information out for you to consider what
you wish to do with this report it had
been submitted to cabinet but the
committee felt that you need the
previous committee felt that you needed
to do more work on it but obviously with
the formation of this new committee you
weren't sure about that and there was a
mix of views at your last meeting as to
not wanting to lose the work from that
review but although members were of the
opinion that we needed to move on
particularly in the post pandemic world
and move forward so it's really with the
committee to decide what you want to do
with it based on that information I sent
out here
what I thought
you better just brother Carol this
nettle damper really a suti you were
quite vocal about about you on your back
Mickey were yes and I appreciate it to
him either work that you put into it and
and I can see why he wouldn't want it
just forgotten about yeah no it's a pity
just forget about it and not finish it
off the the only problem I've got is
that these guys wouldn't involved in it
so would it be really hard for them to
get their heads around what we discussed
in order to help make a decision yeah
and with the greatest respect yourself
I'm one of those guys and it to me the
focus really I must look to you and be
respectful the way you put in so I'm
booking you too - almost lead a teen on
this because for me yeah let's just move
on let's just forget about pull hu I'm
trying to take into consideration
student sorry yes check for clarity the
report is finished the previous
committee completed their work
programming and actually completed the
review the decision would be either to
submit that to cabinet as it stands or
if not what extra the committee wanted
to add to that before it went to
committee as soon as the previous
committee didn't finish what it needed
to do you guys haven't got the capacity
to go over all of it so submit as it
stands because it's pretty good isn't
that
it was a complete report and of course
it was it of its time when members were
looking at some key issues and the world
has moved on since that but as I say
it's a committee decision if you if you
want to submit it and like cabinet see
what you think about it and the
recommendations within it there was
nothing overly controversial or anything
that would cause any problems
to where you might take the work that
you're going to do over the year this
coming year if that's what you like to
do I'm supportive of that about
everybody else how they feel about it
we are a committee here everywhere with
that
okay right then so yeah that's what
we'll give them thank you
all right right thanks everybody for
today's attendance data next meet at
1:00 1:00 p.m. and we're okay with that
okay well thank you very much like so
for your attendance today I can now
declare today meeting closed thank you
you